schwarz um eine electric stuff ist auch
gleich kaputt nein er ist kaputt ich bin
im arsch
hey leute herzlich willkommen zurück zu
einer weiteren folge minecraft minecraft
auf dem server und kämpfern ich fit sein
portal zeigen in dorsten laub und da
dann rot kommen da ich bin hier ja so
als mir das portal in china einzustellen
aufführt du hast mir ja schon gefragt ob
du meine portal nutzen darfst und du
musst dir das ganz genau einprägen wie
es ist weil ich werde jetzt gleich
blöcke blöcke kräften die wahrscheinlich
laut diesem biome sand die form des
landes annehmen werden aber durch die
man durchgehen kann
das heißt du gehst hier und hier ist
mein portal und hier werden blöcke seien
also diese beiden da wo jetzt hier diese
schwarzen sind das werden zwei sand
blöcke seien da kann man noch nicht
durch wird noch das werden zwei sand
blöcke seien durch den spieler durch
kann also genau da wird dein portal
bleiben aus ihr wird es immer sein
portal zu statt blau von demonstriert
durch gehst das ist das thema dann bist
du jetzt in meiner pocket drei menschen
das ist finde ich irgendwie ein bisschen
ungünstig weil wenn das später wirklich
so ist dass ein pocket damit nicht
zuhause zählt ich meine das finde ich
ein bisschen blöd ich meine das ist ja
wie mein keller
ob ich jetzt die ganzen türe mein keller
setzte oder hier da werde ich
benachteiligt das irgendwie kacke cavs
pocket dimension bitte nix briefe wenn
lena bekommt von mir gleich erstmal ist
mein keller
patrick of reality
das habe ich dir gott gegeben das ist
diese schwarze stein so und wir wollen
ja dieser schwarze stein
der ist aber schwarz wir haben hier kam
und plantagen auf den browser
verschiedenste farben
ich glaube wir brauchen alle farben
einmal oder manche zweimal das heißt wir
brauchen erstmal die grundfarben das
heißt wir brauchen blau grün gelb
lebendigkeit blöd wieso keine blau gelb
rot so ist es und rote farbe
wir haben gleich blaue haben aber ich
lasse es genau so cage und das geile ist
stimmt ja außerdem ein feld ich habe ja
damals blumen für die toten gesammelt
hier und ich glaube man kann alle blumen
zu irgendwelchen farben machen
ja round rock wird das geht klar wir
haben war sie blut das kind auch noch
ganz gut denke ich haben wir hier weit
logisch die blaue das haben wir so nicht
aber gelb selbstverständlich davon
nehmen uns ein bisschen mehr wirklich
müssen
klose und da können wir dann hier
beispielsweise jetzt ein bisschen orange
raus machen so cool sind wir nämlich
auch ein crafting käme so immer pocket
menschen das rein so zac wunderbar jetzt
habe ich farben und zwar 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
das sind farben aber das ist ja könnte
hier sei man brauche eine erde die frage
ist ich hoffe den block ihn war hin weil
ich habe mir das war im offline dreien
gezogen
ich habe es natürlich mal getestet weil
ihr es schön wenn ihr mir alle tipps
gibt in die kommentare
aber ich muss sie natürlich erstmal
schauen ob es den block überhaupt gibt
weil viele argumentieren von der neueren
hexe version wo wir grad noch am
diskutieren sind ob überhaupt einsetzen
und deswegen ja nein es geht nicht was
alles nicht ich nicht also nur weil ich
war den beruf studiert bestimmten farben
also ich sehe hier rot grün
okay das ding ist mir fehlt die farbe
grün sehe ich gerade
was genau bringt in dieser glock bringt
das quasi so ein verstecktes portal
machen kannst
genau aber wieso wie viel grün ja wo ich
den grünen
ich musste schon gibt es ja muster was
für farben hier immer drin sind
befristungen goldenes turbo boosts
abnormalen hatte zwei grüne
das ist es ja deswegen scheint
wahrscheinlich nicht zu gehen weil ich
die farbe grün gar nicht habe war leute
guckt euch mal bitte an wie schnell
diese letzte koordinate einfach gerade
hoch geht in der rüstung auf einem
goldenen schoko und ich reite so schnell
voran
es ist krass wie stoffe was passiert ist
mein schoko ich bin auf einer ich war
ihm zu schnell um ein schoko war
irgendwie dann weg ja geil hat sich dann
schön weggepustet ist halt jetzt mein
essen und dessen ränder fehler
chillig schwimm rad durch die welt ich
glaube es war vielleicht ein bisschen zu
schnell wie ich dann unterwegs war
ja weil das logo wurde auch gerendert
seien deswegen vielleicht sollten war
sodann weshalb du kannst ihn herein
blau-weiß ist den wir haben da noch
hellblau schwarz um 1 electric stuff ist
auch gleich kaputt
nein er ist kaputt ich bin am arsch also
irgendwie verstehe ich das jetzt hier
nicht
501 gesehen zwei lapis zwei rote das war
nix schwarz ist dabei ja bitte
ich bin mitten auf mehr
du bist gartenstadt roten reiche ich
kann das nicht
ich habe du bist gerade in stadtlohn ich
wollte ich nicht auf alle ja aber du
bist gerade in statt rot blau statt blau
mancher und sag mal bitte deine letzte
koordinate 1550
damit die mutter bis dahin zurück wo zu
sehen ist 1600 blöcke camouflage passage
gucken wir das jetzt an
hier wird die welt ja nichtmal gerendert
alter du musst nicht auslasten
back-factory leute denn ich verstehe
echt nicht durch diese passenden ich
kriege ich will doch ein schoko und
jetzt wieder zurück jetzt sehe ich
brauche mal rot grün aber das ist bald
auch in zu kommen orange blau ist das
blau was das kjc bruders witz sein laub
ist von braun pink okay wie mache ich
pink rot und blau pink purple oder pink
fehlt aber schwarz
das ist wahrscheinlich dass deswegen ist
bei mir war nicht klappt bei mir schwarz
fehlt da komme ich wir jetzt eine
schwarze haben ich will sie auch noch
ganze zeit bis sie sich gleich viele
schweizer haben so wenig hat musste
jetzt auch nicht die ganze zeit hier so
rum machen so meinel um gemachte und
umgehe
pelikan muss sterben für die fans öffnen
ja ich kenne ihn nicht
das zurück zu stande den jacko
leasing-branche leute drin waren krass
alter das tor sieht richtig geiles wird
uns bis zum eingang
denn wir haben ja mehrere projekte
nebenbei denn ich mache ich bin dabei
ein schweines borner zu machen und dafür
muss ich mindestens 64 schweine töten
und das ist in sousse die fußarbeit weil
spielt hängt am ein portal fest dafür
helfen irgendwie das was ich gerade in
der hand hatte ist jetzt auf jeden fall
weg helfen
ich bin wieder fragen was hat das jetzt
weg noch keines ich hatte nämlich was in
der hand folgt aus dem inventar droppen
wenn gleichzeitig durch meine partei
zugegangen offenbar ist das durch die
portal gegangen mich hat es nicht mehr
erkannt und ich sind nämlich nicht durch
das portal durchgegangen ich kann meinen
blauen rucksack nicht mehr öffnen kann
keine kisten eröffnet oha das kacke muss
disconnect aber da war es irgendwas
passiert der so also nicht passieren
sollte
ich hoffe es klappt jetzt wieder alles
weil das nicht glaubt ja jetzt schon ich
drücke die daumen
ja okay jetzt kann ich alles auf eine
session das wohlhabende stadt blau noch
eben setzen und zwar jetzt hier direkt
vor meinem haus
ich bin nämlich auf der suche nach genau
hast du zufällig ins eck ja ich glaube
schon ich brauchte die mal für eine
befristung links zeigt also diesen
schwarzen stoffen ja ich passe mich mal
von meiner viel frisst du ganz mein
score 2 geben
da kriegst du wieder ich muss nur
schauen ob dafür dass sogar zu recht zu
mir warst ja portal gezeigt wieviel
brauchst du am 28
jetzt gibt tricks 33 jetzt mein haus
weiter wusste meine war danach vom
entsteht ist dass man es wie folgt macht
und zwar aus eher in der mitte gut
danach grün dann schwarz dann blau
ich weiß nicht welches man dass hier was
ist noch nie grau ist auch noch grau
auch noch kaum es mit schwarz und weiß
also ins zeug und bei mir muss ich doch
noch mal was neues kräften so hab ich
gar kein platz mehr in den taxis
vollwertig also grün rot orange offenbar
kein geld vom land und weiß dann grau
dann brauche ich hier orange schwarz
pink und cebu so ich wollte diese dummen
justin time just test transporte es geht
einfach nicht mal ich weiß ich so nicht
den text mache ich mir das ist so
komisch dass er verrückt was willst du
hast du bist immer noch an einem daimler
dieser kamera an fleisch passte will ich
machen damit dieses alf stoff habe und
es geht einfach nicht camouflage ich
dachte besser einem komischen groß block
ja das ist ja diese doch ich brauche
diese passte weil dass dieser kampf
schon wegen behindert alle farben damit
er sich sozusagen seine umwelt anfassten
anpassen kann
aber es will einfach nicht was natürlich
haben alle komplementärfarben denn ich
weiß gar nicht was problem ist alter
wirklich nicht also irgendwie sehr sehr
geil und vor allem stets auch hier
trotzdem war müller minecraft dice okay
das hilft vielleicht es müssen vanilla
minecraft haben sein
das heißt inc sec und sie blue ist kein
weiß ist es auch nicht richtig
ich hab camouflage passte einmal einig
was das bringt karl franz bast ist
scheißegal ich hab sie jetzt einfach
alles was sie bringt ich hab dich
einfach was löst wirklich so völlig egal
ob's was bringt ich habe sie auch nö ich
kann meine tollen diamant kisten nicht
mit den transportern arena
so jetzt aber besser denn fragen ist dir
und zwar brauchen wir jetzt hier vier
glaub ich und dann diese passte in die
mitte jedoch nicht vier passte außenrum
hab die blöcke
guck dir das an ich habe keinen star
peace begriff wie was wo bist du er
starb dabei und ich hab so ein dorf ist
deswegen bin ich relativ langsam
das sind die blöcke ich kann nicht damit
so jetzt zeige ich dir das mal ist jetzt
nicht wahr
ich hoffe das geht auch was denn ich
kann mit einem kisten transport welche
kiste da wird nicht mal blog
hochspringen ja geil ich kommt nicht
hoch wie komme ich nicht dachte ich muss
die kiste halbsätzen das obwohl ich kann
ja so ist etwa ob da jetzt geht also
hier ist vielleicht ein schlechter aber
wenn ich sage mal hier diese tür soll zu
sein und es geht wie geil ist das denn
das ist wirklich geil
barry und sichtbarkeit machende
unsichtbarkeit blöcke ich bin bei dir
läuft wasser erzeugen so mein haus an
was fällt dir auch was hat sich
verändert
okay ich bin verguckt mal hier bekommst
du hier hinter dir so hier war doch
einen durchgang hier damals
dadurch ist das geil
das ist frech das passt sich jedem block
an egal welchem alter das ist geil
das kaff dem rezept sagt mir nicht mehr
kann ich dir sass kann kann ich sagen
wie das heißt es aber dass welche
aufwendig ist halt verschiedene was ist
nennt sich ghost abstand blog-post dass
ab und an ist ganz komisch aus vier
elemente blog von wegen und damit will
ich von wegen alle meine eingänge so
bisschen sperren damit die leute
sozusagen einfach nicht wissen wo es ist
meist selbst machen möchte ich finde
damit vorbeifliegen das dann von wegen
sagt ich muss jetzt immer diese kann
durch elf kann nicht sein
ja das ist ganz klar ich brauche so
junge ich muss jetzt immer halbe teile
dabei haben damit ich die blöden treppen
hoch laufen kann
es gibt nur einen fehler an diesen
blöcken und zwar wenn du jetzt durch das
portal erstarrt droht gehst gleich dann
wirst du merken dass die einen ticken
heller sind als die normalen blöcke hast
du also aber mit leben
wie passen sich an der landschaft an
deswegen sollte es denke ich nicht so
schlimm sein kommt ziemlich geil alter
mein look 1 0 2 zack zack das kommt
wirklich sehr sehr geil
das ist richtig gut
also das feld denke ich gar nicht
aufhören vorbei doch das feld wobei ein
bisschen auf aber naja
es fehlt total egal was andere blöcke
sind deswegen das sind ja keine sand
blöcke sondern das habe ich aus versehen
ins enstone gemachter wunder ist anders
aussieht muss aus dem wie sand wie
machst du das jetzt wie sagst du da
jetzt und carlos im sand also das was
außen rum ist glaube ich so ist das ganz
einfach sozusagen bin ich fast sagen
nicht voll wenn ich jetzt so mache
müssten sie zusammen werden
genau aber ich mache das glaube ich
anders ich stelle die einen weiter innen
rein
das helle von dem nicht so raus scheint
auch weil wir müssen eigentlich ja so
erfordern diese kisten werden dann
irgendwann mal sortiert wenn ich dann so
eine sortier folge mache weil sonst weil
sich sonst ist das irgendwie kacke wenn
ich jetzt die ganze zeit so weiterleben
die ganze die kisten sind nicht sortiert
ist immer noch bei deinem bei deinem
großglockner was machst du gerade in
sand hernehmen soll
so jetzt hierzu ich habe noch ein
bisschen sand glaube ich hoffe ich am
meisten kisten was die ganze folge
online-blog abgebaut ist es natürlich um
chor nicht gerade cool
leider nein leider gar nicht so das
schild kanten weg zwar beide blog typen
ein
denn hier muss ja so einer folge wird
man in ein anderes haus komplett
begradigt alter ich habe schon alle
sachen hier in einer anderen sache in
meinem anderen haushalt also was heißt
in einem anderen haus es ist ja noch
kein haus es ist einfach und grundstück
mit kisten bisher eine absteige eine
billige absteigen
fast gleich richtig nicht so frech mit
mona was richtiger wäre ich aber bockig
du so dann mache ich mir dieses doofe so
album es zumindest ihr sollt es denke
ich passen und ich hoffe das wird auch
das war zu was aber wir haben andere
lücke ich weiß ja nicht was ich mit dem
machen soll
ich frag mich was ehrlich gesagt hier
ist wenn ich den ich hier leben setzt
oder wird auch zu dem schwarzen block
wie auch zu dem schwarzen block also
natürlich sehr uncool
aber jetzt habe ich den irgendwo
hingesetzt und weist nun erlebt er ist
dass hier was hast du märz grad wird für
schwarze blöcke gegeben was kann ich mit
denen machen
das sind einfach blöcke du brauchst für
portale law center perlen und damit
kannst du dir aber wenn du eine ender
perle braucht sonst für jedes rezept und
wenn du da von vier blöcken imst und
einander perle klickst du vier teams die
gleichwertig sind wie ender perlen das
heißt du [ __ ] rendertrailer ok-chef
steht wieder halb kölner oper la bohème
ich hätte die stadt auch weiter bauen
noch für für eine minute oder für zwei
grade ich liebe jetzt wenn man denkt
einmal mehr dass im nächsten folge also
ich gehe da jetzt schon hin
naja kann es machen aber ich begradigen
auch die eben genau hast du eventuell
noch erde da müsstest du mein kissen
gucken das kann ich so nicht sagen
als es aber nicht wo ist mein rucksack
noch da
so war dann legt nämlich schon mal los
hier einfach ein bisschen zu bauen
das heißt ich werde in der stadt droht
jetzt eine schöne bar bauen das volk
leiter dieser durchgang ist echt cool
welcher entstehen in den untergrund ja
ich meine von meiner seite aus ich meine
das was ich gebaut habe deute sich ein
bisschen makaber na da kann man schon
bisschen mehr machen sind wir können ja
noch ein bisschen mehr schmücken somit
sowohl er wolle und so so so blauer
wolle vielleicht er muss als schön
aussehen also untergrund mäßig halt so
ich wollte hier glaub ich ein bisschen
glas machen das heißt brauche sand und
sand habe ich hier ganz viel anderes
hier eine kiste und workbench und stein
es gut ist wenn ich jetzt am untergrund
arbeite kann ich die ressourcen behalten
das ist fantastisch
ok cool ich habe jetzt mein haus ist
quasi begradigt ich werde das jetzt noch
den den denn hier zum damit kann ich
auch richtig schnell stein der ex jetzt
noch die schoko farben so ein bisschen
anders machen hier dass das vielleicht
ein bisschen schöner aussieht
würdest du da müsst ihr jetzt
theoretisch eine fackel draus ich weiß
gar nicht wo ich keine partien setzten
soll ich mache glaube ich einfach so
hier so ein bisschen rein machen es also
was mich persönlich selber stören würde
wenn er ist immer von der decke tropft
ich mag das nicht so wenn ja was meine
ja ich lasse das diese partikel manche
mag es nicht stören aber ich finde das
sieht übels übergriffe aus und über das
rote alter mann könnte in den untergrund
eine richtig geile grotte bauermann das
ist mein plan
klatten idee richtige grotten idee aber
wir müssen unsere folge jetzt auch jeden
moment wieder beenden weil wir damit am
ende angelangt sind so ja und da würde
ich sagen wenn es euch gefällt gibt
einen kommentar ab und dann würde ich
sagen servus einfach in der nächsten
folge bleibt geilo macht gut bist dann
job